Every movie and TV fan knows that these days,
avoiding spoilers is becoming harder and harder.
But what happens when it isn't a poster, trailer,
or even early screening that hints at or spoils
major plot beats - but scenes in the movie
itself?
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Spoilers
Hidden in Popular Movies.
Back to the Future
It's nearly impossible to spoil this time-travel
trilogy, since the fun isn't in knowing whether
Marty and Doc change history, but actually
doing it.
Still, fans could have predicted that sending
Marty back to the future wouldn't go smoothly.
The paper cut-out of Harold Lloyd hanging
from a clock tower in "Safety Last!" hints
at the film’s climax in the opening minute.
Tangled
The baby Rapunzel doesn't spend much time
at home before being kidnapped, but it wasn't
the tragedy it seemed.
You could say her trauma was destiny at work:
just take a look at the mobile in her crib.
There's a sign of her pet lizard Pascal, a
Rubber Duck for the tavern she visits on the
run, the horse Maximus, and more, all giving
hints at her coming adventure.
The Prestige
Everyone who's seen the movie knows that director
Christopher Nolan left plenty of hints to
the twist ending of The Prestige - but did
you realize he also let the secret slip to
his biggest rival magician?
Viewers get the spoiler through narration.
You might think it's referring to the two
stars, but when you realize Christian Bale
was actually playing twins, the line gives
the entire twist away in the first scenes.
Frozen
It broke every Disney fan's heart when they
found out Prince Hans was really a villain
in disguise.
His plan was a subtle one, but fans missed
one of the biggest clues that he wasn't as
innocent as he seemed.
When soldiers corner and try to kill Queen
Elsa, Hans comes to the rescue, but accidentally
knocks down a chandelier which almost kills
her anyway.
But look closer: Hans spots the crossbow,
then takes a quick look at the chandelier
before jumping into action.
He made it seem like an accident, but his
plan to take Elsa out was clear for those
who caught it.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Star-Lord has a knack for nicknames when it
comes to his alien partners, and goes deep
into his childhood for Groot, the walking
tree.
Most fans will get the reference to Shel Silverstein's
childrens’ book "The Giving Tree", but if
they remembered the story, they might realize
how closely it follows Groot's journey.
He grows flowers to help his friends, loses
his branches, and eventually sacrifices his
entire body for the boy he loves.
But just like in the book, the tree was happy.
Captain America: The First Avenger
Double meanings and foreshadowing are often
used to throw a wink to the audience, but
nobody could have guessed that Captain America's
big screen solo movie would launch him into
the future, ready to lead the Avengers into
action.
Well, there was one person who knew that his
and Steve's path was going to send them into
the next century.
Ace Ventura: Pet Detective
The surprise ending to this detective story
is played for a ton of laughs, with the revelation
that police lieutenant Lois Einhorn was Ray
Finkle in a previous life.
The jokes at her expense are all pretty childish,
and so was one of the biggest hints at her
true identity, revealed through a few pieces
of fruit on her desk.
Looper
The hero of this film winds up doing everything
he can to prevent a telekinetic young boy
from becoming a horrible crime lord in the
future, going by the name of 'The Rainmaker.'
Although he succeeds, the name is never explained...
but it IS hinted at.
Before the protagonist even arrives at the
boy's farmhouse, audiences get a look at a
futuristic flying drone used to water the
surrounding crops.
If they realized this "rain-maker" was the
key, they could've gotten the twist a whole
lot sooner.
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
Keeping the events of the Harry Potter series
under wraps was a major priority for author
JK Rowling.
But one of the story's biggest surprises was
hinted at in just the third movie.
When Harry is injured during a Quidditch match,
he wakes up to his friends, with the Weasley
twins defending him with a threat.
They couldn't have known it then, but that
same fate would fall on Albus Dumbledore,
thrown from the Astronomy Tower to his death
three movies later.
Casino Royale
Directors often use symbols to clue the audience
in on their characters, but using them to
spoil the movie in the opening credits isn't
as common.
In Casino Royale's credits, Vesper Lynd's
character is revealed as both the Queen of
Hearts and the Queen of Spades.
For those who know their suits, that means
she's a symbol of love, and a symbol of bad
luck or betrayal - revealing her character's
double-cross, setting in motion multiple sequels.
Those are all the details, twists or plot
points spoiled in major films, but which clues
have we missed?
Share them in the comments and don't forget
to subscribe for more videos like this one.